(Gary imitates laser firing)
- What's up, Nate? (imitates laser firing)
(gunshots booming)
- Wait, you own this game?
- No dude, I told you,
I don't own this game.
I own the Minnesota franchise
of this game in the league.
Find out on this WeeklyVee.
(dramatic music)
If you do not love losing, you lost.
♪ I feel I can't lose ♪
♪ I'm mortal, immortal, immortal ♪
(upbeat music)
- Hey everyone, I'm Zain
and I'm a community resident on Team Gary.
So what that means is a
lot of my time right now
is focused around community management
initiatives across different platforms.
What you're about to see is a meeting
that Team Gary had in
a hotel room with Gary,
to get his thoughts on a couple
of S&D, surprise and delight initiatives
that we're really excited about.
Hope you enjoy.
- I think where we're going
is not working for me.
It's the same as the 90 second
club is not working for me.
I think we are dictating from the top
and using money, which lacks soul.
I think what we need to go into
and it's why I hired you Zain,
is community management
up and then doing things
that are authentic and shocking.
Like when I bought
burger that was literally
searching somebody who said
they were hungry for a burger.
I think we need to go there.
Right now we're going way too much
into a territory that I
don't feel good about.
Now that we have the weekly vlog,
I think one of the things we can consider
is if Zain knows I'm in Boston,
or Minnesota this week, he
can start looking for things.
Like let me play it out at scale.
He's just looking for interesting things.
Boom, he finds something interesting.
He clicks, person's in Minnesota.
Boom, now we can talk about logistics.
Now Alex and Lou get something.
Like Zain maybe hits them up,
or figures out where they...
Me showing up to their house delivering
a cupcake and then being out, is content.
I'd rather do that four times a year,
then get tickets every week.
And then we could use the team to scale.
We can film this, we could use this moment
over and over as an overlay
of how we got to it.
And now it's the 19th of April,
May comes in and is like,
blah blah blah blah.
I'm like, May go to fucking
Orlando right now and do this.
I sign the book.
May then goes with Dustin
literally to the airport,
literally flies to Orlando.
Literally goes to the person's house,
literally delivers a signed
book, literally flies back.
That piece of content intermixed
into WeeklyVee is the payoff.
That investment of 1400 bucks
is way fucking doper
than the $1400 tickets,
that are coldless, that
are uninteresting content.
You'd be using money.
I actually think if you play that out,
we should almost go into
surprise and delight Dean.
Dean just happens to be on the team
and I was trying to think of Dean.
(upbeat music)
I think we should hire somebody
who's job it is to constantly fly around
and surprise and delight on my
behalf, in real time, always.
Literally like once a week
something's gonna happen
and it's like, they wear a zip cam,
or whatever the fucking,
just like, fucking let's go.
- [Drock] It's for the content right?
- No it's for surprising
the fuck out of somebody.
Next, it's for the content.
To do that to spread the
message of positivity and good.
Which of course will have
selfish awareness towards
the brand, but it's what we wanna do.
I do plenty of good things hidden.
- So I hope you guys
enjoyed that inside peak
at our surprise and
delight, S&D discussion.
You know, keep your eyes out for S&D Dean.
You might be getting a
special visit from him soon.
And now the rest of the vlog.
- [Audience Member] My thing is now
that I love these other things,
I'm like, now I just wanna do out there
and just do the best
of these other things.
And now do I just jump in a ship
that I don't know, but I like it?
- Yes, with ways that if you go to zero,
doesn't put you guys out.
- [Audience Member] Right.
- What are we doing here?
In the most simple
question, option A, option B
of real life, you die at 87
and you fucking liked
it, but you have $30.
Or you die at 87, and you didn't like it
and you have 1.9 million.
Like who?
Who cares about that?
Usually they resent the
fact that their kids
are taking it and they don't give
a fuck as much as they did to get there.
It's like a double loss.
You have the money, but you're pissed
at your kids and then you're dead.
You're better being fucking happy,
as often as humanly possible.
- [Audience Member] Yeah
a lot of people chase
the money and they think
that's gonna make them happy.
- Almost everybody.
- [Audience Member] Everybody
does, 99% of people.
- That's why Instagram
looks the way it does.
That's the game.
Read my comments.
They all think I'm full of shit.
They're like, fuck you,
super easy to be happy
when you have money.
I'm like, 'cause you didn't
know me when I didn't.
Fuck you.
- [Audience Member] The game is fun.
That's what I find is fun,
when there's challenges and I just do it.
I don't care if I win or lose.
- 100%.
- [Audience Member] Just go for it.
- People are like, oh what's the strategy
behind your garage sale?
I'm like, it's my favorite thing to do.
Big strategy.
I love the fuck out of it.
Like literally yesterday, I was like,
oh it's January, four more months,
garage sale season, trash
talk's gonna be back.
We're gonna have some fun.
Just struck big.
This is the little part of it.
But this is the big part.
The submarine.
Picked it up for three.
She wanted five, she didn't get it.
She didn't get it.
I like it.
And then they're like, no you didn't make
as much money as you thought.
Gary, the gas costs money.
I'm like, the gas costs money
for you to go to work, dick.
- Yo yo yo, it's the
beach boy, Yung Pinch.
You're about to listen to Beach Ballin',
featuring blackbear, while
watching the WeeklyVee, let's go.
♪ I think that there's nobody
in the world that gets me ♪
♪ Oh no-oh ♪
♪ I could tell you how I feel
but then you won't forget me ♪
♪ Oh no-oh ♪
♪ Yeah, then I'm beyond lit ♪
♪ Yeah, I be all in ♪
- Gianna, hey it's Gary.
First of all, thank you so
much for watching my TikToks.
Thank you so much for your epic video.
You were so good on camera, first of all.
Pay attention to trending
topics and hashtags.
Trending topics is a huge way.
So every time you see a trending song,
or a trending topic, try to
be creative and be honest.
You know how you like that I keep it real,
you have to keep it real too.
You can't do what Charli
or Andrea or whatever.
Do you, but look for the topics
that people are excited about.
And always do things that
you feel right about.
Eventually it will come.
(upbeat music)
- What's up Vary nation.
This is Jake from Team
GaryVee, AKA Meme Lord.
And we're gonna do
what's on their desk bit.
So come check it out.
(upbeat music)
All right, so this is where I'm posted up.
This is HQ, we call it.
We got the computer where
the magic happens, of course.
And then when you're on
the side hustle, you know.
Got the Nintendo Switch, get some game in.
This is Oinkers.
(pig oinking)
He makes a little oinking noise.
We call this the infinity cube,
'cause it's a perpetual loop of flipping.
It's harder to do with one hand.
But you kinda get it right there.
Great for thinking up ideas
and memes and what not.
Oh this is kinda fire.
Get a close up on my bills.
You got the bread, the stacks, the stacks.
GV stacks.
And Gucci Mane stacks.
These are good at most
banks, so that's big.
SpongeBob kind of art piece.
Very nice.
Leave a comment below what you think.
Give it a score out of 10.
And let's see your desk, how it stacks up.
- What's like the advice you would give,
especially the younger people,
to be like, give a freaking shit
about all those stuff
that can make it happen?
- I try to say it in a
million different ways.
What came to mind right
now is remember how much
high school sucked because you had
to worry about popular kids opinions?
Well you're doing that now on Instagram.
- Yeah.
- Get out of this fucking game.
That's why I'm so proud of
Instagram for doing it for us.
People hate the algorithms, I love them.
They care about the end consumer staying.
They know that this is
creating insecurity,
so they took away the likes.
I want them to take away the followers.
- Straight up.
Take away my blue check mark
too, while you're at it.
I don't need it.
And if it's creating you insecurity
that you think I'm cooler
than you because of it,
get it the fuck out of there.
I really mean it.
A, I prefer that we
build up our self esteem,
so we are not worried about it.
But this is just like, we need just
a big social conversation
of what success is.
And we need to reframe
it towards happiness,
not financial success or status success.
- Is happiness, that's what you're
striving for every single day?
- I think so.
And a lot of people are like,
Gary you don't mean happiness,
you mean fulfillment.
I'm like, bro whatever fucking
word you wanna call it, good.
Call it good.
Feeling good.
Like you wanna put some different
spin on the word, mazel tov.
But for me, it's about am
I happy, or am I not happy?
And I think parents
pressure kids to be doctors
because that status in their subculture
leading the kid to be unhappy.
People want money.
There's just so much insecurity.
And I am fascinated by
the people that I see
that are the most content and happy.
And a lot of it has to do with
being able to calibrate opinion.
And I think people think, I have to do
a better job this next decade of saying,
it's not that I don't give a fuck,
it's that I'm actually empathetic
that you can't know me
if you don't know me.
And so I think it's just so easy for me
to calibrate judgment because
it can't carry weight.
They don't have enough data.
That's what I want for people.
Like who are you trying
to impress, for what?
- Hey guys, I'm Raghav.
I'm a copy writer on Team GaryVee.
This next meeting that
you're about to watch
is Gary teasing out a secret project
that we've been working on
for a while in the team.
Hope you guys enjoy.
- Guys we may kill this
before they're produced.
I hope you've been around the block.
Like I feel excited, I'm
shocked we're this far.
I'm really into it.
This could be my life.
It could be the rest of my life.
It's gonna be the rest of my life.
This might go so bat shit crazy,
that this is what I do and I decide
to build this as a billion dollar IP
and that's what literally
I do for a living.
Or we might kill it before it launches.
But if it could be a billion dollar IP
and it's what I do, I don't
know if I wanna lock in
to the origin story right this second.
Cool, makes sense?
♪ 1997 to my dying days ♪
♪ I'm a get his money,
I'm a ride my wave. ♪
♪ Blunt town, beach boy,
who you trying play? ♪
♪ I can't lose, gotta be
successful I'm a find a way. ♪
- [Interviewer] How's your
Garyvee search engine going?
And what was the idea behind that?
- The idea behind that was
we built it for ourselves.
So we were using it for ourselves
and now we've made it front-facing.
We've given it a little push,
we're gonna give it a bigger push.
We're making it better and better.
At some point I'm gonna really push it.
It's great.
You're sitting here, you're
gonna fly back to Australia
and be like fuck I wanted
to ask him about this.
You can literally type that
in and fucking find it.
If I've said it.
It's fucking gnarly.
Plus we're systematically
structuring the data for voice.
Hey Alexa, I want to speak to Gary.
Gary would I manage a
manager who's poison?
And then I'm gonna start talking.
I have to be careful to not
show how strategic it all is.
You know, because my team like,
it's been written, is
what I will tell you.
This is over.
I'm just the only one that knows.
I genuinely think I will be
the single most famous
person in the world.
I really believe that.
(soft piano music)
I really do.
- [Interviewer] Why is it important to you
when you say, "I'm gonna
be the most famous person
"in the world."
What's the "why" behind that?
- 'Cause I'm a good person
and I'm gonna make people better.
(soft piano music)
It's better for me to be the best
or most known person than somebody else.
It's really cool,
I wanna hear it, let me just say this.
And what some of the
26-year-old guys in the crowd,
I'm telling you.
Nobody knows, I know.
Like Lou, coming in or you knowing me.
I'm making a really significant impact
on 15 to 25-year-old dudes.
I've absolutely am changing the lexicon.
True?
It's real.
It's fucking real.
I watch it.
We were in this crazy era of of like,
I've said it yesterday I'll say it again.
Real low common denominator
of what success,
what winning looked like.
And it was getting worse by the second.
Because of the imagery on Instagram.
And I really am proud.
Like genuinely proud, leaving a legacy.
I really think I've made an impact.
By me winning so much
and spinning this talk,
the video I made yesterday
is heralding an employee
that I ran into who
was catering a function
as a VaynerMedia employee.
And I was emotional, let alone excited.
This guy right here,
this guy right here.
Works at Vaynormedia.
What's he doing right now?
Side hustling, working the party.
- That's right.
- He's the only person I grabbed tonight
and said you inspire me so much.
I look up to you so much.
That's fucking mindset,
that I fucking admire.
- I appreciate that.
- I'm fucking proud of you bro.
So proud of him to have the
humility to fucking busboy
or serve for a caterer because
he's grinding out here.
And I'm putting him on a fucking pedestal.
Not the fucking kids
that are tricking people
to have a checkbox in
a eCommerce execution
that creates a 12-24 recurring
revenue, like people...
Good shit.
I'm really proud of it.
I want the attention because
I know what to do with it.
- Hey baby, it's a check.
'Scribe that for a
1,000, Child of Bus-town
to violent you know viper.
And you listening to Can't Stop Finessing
on WeeklyVee.
♪ You can't take my life away ♪
♪ You can't away my genius ♪
♪ I guess I make it look too easy ♪
♪ Why they running off with the sauce ♪
♪ Guess I made it look too easy ♪
♪ Probably made it look too easy ♪
- WeeklyVee what's good?
So we did this offsite.
Part of this big conference,
I did a conference in Australia.
And then the people there able
to package new small conferences.
Execute very small groups
in New York, London.
Australia just was a final piece of,
Sydney, London, New York.
So much fun.
And I use this for data.
Because I'm thinking about like,
do I want to do a cruise ship?
Like a excursion for 14 days?
I don't know, just fucking thinking.
I think we should
document you in WeeklyVee
going through this process
so advertises out the value.
Mike, come on!
It advertises out the value of it.
Here's an example.
Like we should talk about
what we talked in there
which is this is getting how we passed
and we deeply probably
intuitively aren't sure
if this is great ROI or a horrible ROIs
always be testing.
- WeeklyVee, sometimes Gary
Vee values killer results.
Other times he values learnings
in the fortune cookie campaign.
He values learnings.
Here's the fortune cookies
that are going to be inserted
in some fortune cookies hopefully
at a Chinese restaurant nearest you.
(upbeat music)
What you think, it's good?
Fire.
- Get Caleb, come on get in here!
Caleb!
Guys, this is bullshit.
Get in here.
Watch this.
Get in here Max.
It's not full up.
Max get in here, this is
all fucking family, dick!
Get in here there's more, I want more.
Get in here.
Max butt!
Max!
- So as you can see like,
Gary's just trying to pack
the elevator full of
people way over capacity.
Way too packed, way over the weight limit.
Terrifying.
(quacking)
- All right one more person, let's go.
Mike, Mike, get in here Mike!
Mike, get in here Mike!
Mike we're not leaving without you.
Looks good everybody,
this is WeeklyVee, O-O-3.
- [Mike] Tomorrow night
you're really gonna eat.
- I don't know if I'm gonna really eat.
I've also not eaten in two days.
(laughs)
- [Mike] Tomorrow's gonna be light.
- [Gary] I'll see what I
can do, I'll let you know
- What they have eaten fish.
- [Gary] Food.
Like a Caesar salad with shrimp.
- [Mike] That's fine.
- I'll fight.
- [Mike] Let me know.
- [Mike] Cool.
- I'll let you know about the wine.
I'll fight.
- [Mike] See you guys.
- Going through it with, like.
We're good thank you.
I'm trying to get serious
about losing some weight again.
Like I went, I lost all
that weight six years ago.
And then four years worth of like,
slowly but surely, 190 to 158.
And then--
- [Cale] 158?
- 158.
And now 158 back to like 182.
- [Cale] And how old were you at 190?
- 38.
And then I built up a ton of muscle.
But the last year because
Jordon and I as a team
kind of fazed the last six months
and then Mike and Jordon
did three months each
and that kind of was a little clunky.
So last year was definitely
like the weakest nutrition
and you can see in the content like,
some really on it.
Like I've been really doing
some good work the last,
since December 1st.
But during the holidays I went off it.
But like me and Mike are in it.
- [Cale] What's your favorite lift?
- So as the videographers
we love to just like
provide random little
tidbits of Gary's life.
And this is a moment
where he's talking about
lifting and his physique.
And I used to be a power lifter so this
is something that I like to
talk to him about here and there
when the opportunity arises.
- Which body part?
- [Cale] Like do you like bench press,
do you like squat, deadlift, curls.
- I mean I like, legs are the worst.
Fucking worst.
I like back.
- [Cale] I love back.
- I like back too.
- [Cale] Do you ever deadlift?
- Yeah, Jordon was very into it.
- [Cale] Yeah, yeah.
- I like it.
- [Cale] Yeah.
- I do like it.
I like bench, I like trap exercises.
I'm definitely in it though now.
I feel like I'm gonna
look sharp in six months.
- [Driver] I always feel like
if you get into the routine.
- Yeah.
- You stay in the routine.
- I was in the routine.
So I went all the way
down but then the routine
for the last three years
became muscle gain.
Like the level of muscle I
have compared to where I was.
But the last year, especially
the last six months
of last year, like I
went from 158 to 170 over
like four, 3 1/2 years.
And I went 170 to 180 in like six months.
And that's when I was like, uh-oh.
And that's why me and Mike are
like really going hard now.
Now I'm fucking fasting.
And now like, I'm already from
182 which is the worst number
like 183, I'm already at
like 170, 176 this morning.
So a good start.
(upbeat music)
Yeah, so we're at the Senior Bowl
which is like the big All-Star game
for college football players
heading into the NFL draft.
And we've got three
VaynerSports participants.
Which is exciting.
And it's exciting to be here,
just Brandon Parker
here from VaynerSports.
Look how cool this guy is, look at him.
Looks like Deon in the 90s.
- I wish, see you later.
- What's going on, I'll see you later.
- GaryVee!
- What's good bro?
- What's up man?
- How are you?
- [Supporter] Dude, I love you bro.
- Thank you bro, I love you back.
This is really cool.
Like I really love football.
And if you look D. Rock
show 'em, like this is not.
This is like an All-star game
this is really for the scouts
not the fans, like if you
look up, show right here.
This is not a sellout crowd,
this is not the fucking Superbowl.
This is where the fucking
real shit goes down,
where you're really
putting in in the work.
Where you're really building a company
this is Mobile, Alabama.
And you're really here if
you're in the football business.
You know, this is not a football fan stuff
this is football business stuff.
And now I'm in both.
That's cool, that was cool.
I gotta do a call with client.
Actually this is really good.
If you're curious how we do it
I'm now calling a Fortune-500 CEO.
♪ First things first, they
can all get the work ♪
♪ I'm the best at my worst ♪
♪ Pull up in Suburbans,
bitches all like, Brr ♪
♪ Nigga you so cold ♪
♪ How your wrist so froze ♪
All right, real problem here.
Bill Belichick is here,
the coach of the New England Patriots.
And if you know me you know I
hate me some Bill Belichick.
So we're gonna walk by him right now
and try to keep our emotions in check.
Otherwise.
(dramatic music)
Way to run it out Mack.
My guy.
It's good to see you.
All right bro.
He's wearing number five.
I'm all set.
He's wearing number five
that means we're set.
I saw Belichick, and I don't like it.
You're on the other side on the 40?
I see you.
All right got you.
Okay, I'm gonna go over there
because Darnay's over there.
- Hey guys this is AJ, I was the dude
that Gary was just on the
phone with, also his brother.
And business partner.
And so we are down here in Mobile, Alabama
for the Senior Bowl.
And so the Senior Bowl
is one of the most
important All-Star games,
it's the top All-Star game when it comes
to the pre-draft process.
What they do is they
invite the top seniors
and other graduated
students in the country
to compete on two sides
and practice all week
and compete in a game in Mobile.
And it's important for us to be down here.
One, we have three clients
that played in the game,
Darnay Holmes from UCLA.
Steven Montez from Colorado,
and Austin Mack from Ohio State
so just good for Gary to see the guys,
support the guys, we bring
most of our team down.
But it's also just great
networking with the teams.
So an opportunity to meet with GMs
and head coaches and scouts.
Just to get a feel and ignore that buzz.
Get a feel for you know, the
perception of our players.
Not just the three guys in the game.
But we have 13 members
of this draft class, so.
Just one of the main touch points
between being at Senior Bowl,
the Combine in Indianapolis,
things in that nature,
just an important part
of the draft process.
- Are you guys close in speed?
- Yes.
- I think so.
- Really?
- I actually think
we're very close.
Didn't we do something?
- You're in better shape than me.
- Yeah, but we did something, AJ.
The reason I responded
that way is I thought
we did something that
made us be like oh shit,
we're gonna have to race.
We're gonna fucking race, Pay-Per-View.
- So Gary and I are super competitive.
I think both of us think
we're better than each other
at so many different things.
And we both have
different points of views.
I think there's one thing that we agree on
it's that we're both slow.
We just, I think we're we're
athletic in our own right
and in different ways, we've
got good hand-eye-coordination
I won't drop a pass.
Things of that nature.
But goodness we're just not fast,
and we both know it.
- Yeah, I got big hands.
- Yeah, AJ's got much bigger
hands than I do though.
Like, you know?
- That's pretty close.
- Actually, your thumb is big.
- You both low-key got
big hands for your height.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I AJ, on catching it'd be close.
I catch the ball well too.
(upbeat music)
D. Rock it's gonna be good for WeeklyVee.
I did some fun stuff.
- [Driver] I'm gonna walk by
and try to compose myself.
- [Gary] Just like say funny stuff.
- I'm gonna try not to move my shit.
(laughs)
- I was eight percent there
to like ask him for a photo
and then like post it on
Instagram and be like,
I hate this man.
That's it, just that, that's it.
(graphics whirring)
(screen whooshes)
What's good everyone?
Thursday morning, here in Mobile Alabama.
About to give a speech
here at the Senior Bowl.
A business summit that we're gonna have
a couple of VaynerSports meetings,
then we're gonna go
connect in Dallas to Boston
land in Boston at like
1:40 in the morning,
I didn't even realize
they land at that time.
Anyway, speak at Harvard tomorrow morning,
off to Minesota,
bunch of VaynerMedia
operational calls in between.
That's where we're at.
I was out super late last night
with a bunch of General Managers.
Which was fun, with AJ.
I like tagging along
with him at VaynerSports
and so that's where we're at.
Keynote time.
- I know you say to people
who don't know what their passions
are to try a lot of stuff.
- Yes.
- My thing is how, where
do you start with that?
- Okay, let's play.
You're 19, which I'm so thrilled
you're asking this question
because it's super important.
This thought that you need
to have your life figured out
at this stage is laughable.
This thought that we've created
in society that 18 or 22
you need to know and you go,
it's like we've literally
built society backwards.
Like, when you first get
out of the school machine
which maps zero to real life.
You're supposed to go play
real life to have a chance
to figure out what you do.
So, where do you start?
You start with what are
consuming and paying attention
to when you have leisure time.
Do you play video games?
Do you listen to music?
Do you like to go out and eat weird food?
What do you like?
That's where you start.
So what do you like, Ahmed?
Like, what are you about?
- I'm kind of a geek.
I like things like comic books.
- Good, let's start with comic books.
Do you wanna create comic books,
do you wanna sell comic books,
do you wanna buy comic
books and flip them,
do you wanna work at ComiCon?
All of those things would be
a good place for you to start.
Cold email and DM 850 different
people that are players
in the comic book world,
and one of them might reply to you
and that starts your career.
Like you could literally
work for FunCo tomorrow.
You could literally work
for Marvel tomorrow.
You could.
You just have to write
137 compelling emails
and DMs and LinkedIn things.
(audience laughing)
what's that brother?
- I said you could literally
do that in your bed.
- Yeah, bro you can literally do that.
(audience laughing)
Who's 43 and older?
We couldn't do that, Ahmed.
(audience laughing)
That's not how it worked.
When we were coming up the game.
You didn't just like, say eh.
Actually ironically once in
a while I come across an OG
who's like actually I did do that.
I wrote 800 letters.
It took two months for
me to get a response.
Instead of two hours.
But yeah man, you know in the comic world
there's the movie aspect,
there's the actual skill of it.
Like if you like the drawing of it,
look let me tell you
one thing about winners.
A lot of winners didn't
get there by accident.
So when you write a winner an email,
Your favorite illustrator
at DC comics, Hey Sarah.
I will bring you coffee, get your laundry
grind and bleed, just to
intern or work at minimum wage
just to see how you do it.
One out of every 100 of those people,
that's how I hire.
I hired D. Rock because
he emailed me three times.
And now he's D. Rock and people call
their video people D. Rock.
(audience laughing)
- Look there he is!
- [Gary] I'm here.
- What's up man.
- [Gary] What's up man?
- So I'm sitting there I'm
like in 30 grand a month
all right for me in Alabama.
- [Gary] That's a lot of money.
- That's a lot of fucking money.
- [Gary] So you took the step back?
- I got four kids, your video was like man
if you really wanna fast-track success
I think you used D. Rock,
people that are like next to me.
- [Gary] Get close to the sun.
- Yeah, that's exactly what it was.
And you know what I had
opportunity to become
the CMO for --
- Yeah.
- And I had to go there.
I had to go back to 15k to 2k a month.
And I got four kids, so
it was a big ass risk.
- [Gary] Yep.
- But I got close...
So I got close...
I was his CMO for two years, came out
I stepped out.
Resigned about a year ago.
And let's just say I'm doing
multiple six figures a month.
- I appreciate, I'm trying.
- [Fan] No, no, no I'm just
saying that I follow you man.
- Thank you so much.
- So I just thank you
for that man, that means.
- That makes me happy, offense,
one step backwards three steps forwards.
- And it could really happen.
- Going to VaynerSports
meetings with AJ right now.
And Mike Nelligan wants
to spend marketing dollars
with our athletes, make sure you do that.
And then I'm going to the airport
connecting to Dallas and
heading to fucking Boston
for Harvard talk.
(upbeat music)
Headed to the airport, me
and D. Rock just jamming.
Answering questions.
Speaker, texting, DMing,
promoting the DWayne Wade Karaoke event.
D. Rock shaking his head, he's
happy to be making content.
- Yep.
- 2020 motherfucker.
(upbeat music)
So just got off the plane
in Dallas, headed to Boston.
And I'm fasting today.
- Yeah?
- But Mike said I could have
a little bit of alcohol.
So I decided to have two bloody Mary's.
(Mike chuckles)
- You love life.
- I've only gotten, I like tomato juice.
But I'm a little bit fucking.
(chuckles)
No, I'm not loose, D. Rock.
I'm not fucking loose,
I'm focused as fuck.
(upbeat music)
- [Interviewer] One of
the common misconceptions
that you see when you
mention something like that
and other people, I assume
there's a lot of them
that just don't see the
same thing that you see.
- Well, the good news is that you know,
when I talk about in 40
years being an old man
and talking about this exact weekend.
I'll be like yeah and
the guy interviewing me
was from New Jersey, like you know.
It just, it's obvious to me.
It's already happened
at the consumer level.
I'm not worried about CMOs
and Fortune-500 companies.
Or other men and women
in the business world
who are in finance or
Wall Street seeing it.
This is already happened
with the end-user.
And I think that my whole
career has been built
on seeing things that
have already happened
that the B2B world has not seen.
So I'm deeply consumer-centric.
And I think that anybody
that's been paying attention
to Call of Duty or eSports
or video game culture
recognizes that it's one of
the biggest entertainment
industries in the world by a country mile.
And now it's about
packaging and merchandising.
So, yeah I mean, I would
be lying if I didn't say
as I sit here I believe
this will be footage
that I look back at fondly.
I'm sure a lot of the original
owners of those leagues
that became the leagues we all know
wish there was more footage
during those weekends
'cause obviously they were
at the mercy of the media
they couldn't be doing it
themselves like we all can now.
And so, I'm excited about it.
- Hey we played in the end bracket too,
under ROKKR, we're winning that for sure.
We're on round four right now.
- Is that right?
- [Devin] How are your travels here bro?
- Good man.
I was...
I'm so ready for this.
- I know.
- I was at Harvard this morning.
Doing a lecture then jumped
on a plane and got over here.
So right now vlog, I'm
about to go on the air
on YouTube live, we're at
launch weekend this at ROKKR,
the Florida franchise just
beat the Seattle franchise.
And we're up next.
What I'm doing moments
before is reading comments.
I just went live on Instagram,
some of you saw that.
I just got an email from a client.
I'm working on a new potential client.
Just got a text from AJ about
something on VaynerSports.
That potential client just
asked me is email okay.
I said yes.
You got it.
Thank you so much.
I just posted a Instagram about
a fight I had in high school.
And in middle school, excuse me.
And my friends from middle
school are texting me.
And asking about it.
So that's funny.
And so, you know, just living life.
(hip hop music)
- Guys, I'm literally here
with like my role model dudes.
- It's true, we're here!
- Oh my God.
- We did it bro!
- Can I just give you a hug?
Oh my God dude.
- Look at this mug life.
Look at this mug life.
That's what's up.
Mug life baby.
- Oh my gosh, like,
it's like you changed my life, dude.
Like I recently just
dropped out of college.
I have my own clothing brand,
I'm just making a bunch of
money to go to all these events.
And I'm doing everything
you told me to do.
- You hitting TikTok?
- Of course.
- I friggin' love you dude.
(graphics whirring)
(screen whooshes)
I love pickles.
And olives.
- Hey.
- And tangerines.
- It's a clementine I think.
- Clementine.
(laughing)
Vlog, we're doing more fun shit.
Now we're gonna chop
that, put it on TikTok
and fucking destroy.
Make content.
Don't think about it.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
- Yeah, so we're excited
to watch this today
from the lens of all
of the different people
around the gamer--
- Yes.
- That make these things happen.
- Yeah I think that's right.
- So--
- I mean this is something
you've done your whole life.
You've seen the infrastructure
around the person.
It's funny, I live a life where I'm both.
I'm the person now, which is weird.
But like my whole life,
or more importantly
what VaynerMedia does
and what I understand is the
infrastructure and business
around it, so I agree.
It's a really cool perspective.
- Yeah, good, good.
- Awesome.
- Well--
- Pleasure to meet you brother.
- Pleasure to meet you too.
- Nice to meet you.
- Have a good weekend, thank you.
- Thank you, so so nice to meet you.
Take care.
- Take care.
- [David] I think we can
talk about that more.
- [Gary] What's that?
- [David] Just because like more people
everyone wants to be a rap artist.
- You know that's a good point,
let's talk about it right now.
To D. Rock's point and thanks
for jumping in D. Rock,
this will probably be a cool
transition piece of content.
Yeah, I mean, there's always
the machine around the human.
And to D. Rock's point,
whether you're a rapper
an athlete, and now at
some level all of us.
In the world that I want you to live,
which is be the expert around
making homemade cookies.
Be the expert around
designing on top of sneakers.
Be the expert, D. Rock
made a statement yesterday
about putting out a course
around video and then Chase
got mad because you used
a different company,
you'll figure it out, but.
Almost at some level we're now
of the age of infrastructure
around a human, not just
actor and athlete and musician
now all of us.
I mean I'm an entrepreneur.
Like, let's call it what it is.
I'm a business man.
And I might have the biggest
infrastructure of anybody.
With the way I think about
production of content
and scale as a gateway to all things.
And so much like that lovely lady
who was in the experiential business.
So what that means is
she understood like sure,
Beyonce is gonna be in Minnesota
but what was the three months leading
up to Beyonce being in Minnesota?
And then when Beyonce lands,
who's the style and makeup?
Who's the agent?
Who's the manager?
Who's from the record label?
Who's from the brand Pepsi?
It's a scene.
And what D. Rock's alluding
to and why this content
will hopefully be
successful for a lot of you
is you may wanna be an
eSport celebrity, player.
You may wanna be a rapper.
You may wanna be the entrepreneur,
and back to self-awareness
and having self-esteem,
feeling happy about yourself.
Instead of delusion which
leads to insecurity.
A lot of you are gonna try
to be the best entrepreneur.
The best eSports player,
the greatest fucking rapper.
And you're gonna fail because
you don't have that talent.
Which is okay.
Yet, you could still be, D. Rock
is not the greatest
entrepreneur of all time.
But he's fucking documenting him.
- [David] I don't wanna be.
- No shit.
That's the best part.
- I know.
- And I don't wanna do what
you do better than I do.
And it's just self-awareness.
And so, A to D. Rock's point,
some of you wanna be the
greatest rapper of all time
but you love film and production
so you need to go and find
Da Baby, or Weezy or Drake
and be part of that team.
Some of you just love
production and video.
D. Rock didn't give a
fuck about entrepreneur
we stumbled into each other.
Same with me, I love business.
I didn't like wine.
I love business.
I like the game of business.
And so I will sell and create businesses
around things over the next 50 years
that are not necessarily
my deepest passions
'cause my deepest passion
is the process of building business.
Or, now that I have 25 years of hard work,
I've put myself in a position
to maybe do my deepest passions.
My deepest passions
actually in a very meta way
are loving what you love.
You know, I loved video games playing.
But I wasn't the most obsessed.
But I love loving what you love.
And I know that eSports
is here forever in scale.
And your passion feeds me.
And then I like building
the business around it.
You don't have to be it.
But you can be around it.
If you deploy your self-awareness
then you can actually
be successful around it.
Because a lot of you also
wanna be the D. Rocks
of something and you're
also not a good rapper
and you're also not a good filmer.
But, Lou still too young.
He's good at a lot of things.
But like, what I can tell
you right off the bat
he's been on the admin team
for four seconds fucking operator.
Efficient, tight.
So like maybe you're not the thing,
maybe you're not even
the creator around it
but maybe you're the infrastructure
that fucking makes the machine run
because you're extremely organized.
You're anxious by not acting
on something immediately.
Lou's, I don't wanna call
it anxiety but like--
- [Lou] It is.
- Right, great?
So Lou's unbelievable need,
ready, Gary you have to do homework.
Gary, you have to close this deal.
Gary, you have to go talk to this person.
I'm Procrastinator Pat.
(Lou laughs)
- [Lou] That's funny.
- Like, I'm just like,
what's the last fucking
second I can do that?
Lou is like, Lou, I've got to
go to Pakistan in 13 years.
He's like working on the
fucking trip right now.
(Lou laughs)
As an admin to the Chaos
to Procrastinator Pat,
you may wanna put
Procrastinator Pat in here.
Draw it, Avatah.
That's a huge value prop.
So you may love Devonte Graham
on the fucking Charlotte Bobcats.
You wish you were a
basketball player, can't.
You wish you were his
video blogger, can't.
But can you be his admin?
That makes his life work?
Off the field, off the court?
If you deploy self-awareness
around what you're good at,
you can actually be who you wanna be.
Maybe one or two steps removed.
Self-awareness.
That will help a lot of fucking people.
- [Lou] What was it about?
- Are you still filming?
Like I actually want it
to end with you putting
it down there and you
and I actually go wow,
like you know?
That's how I think the clip should end.
You know just a little
bit of a different end.
That might give it a little something.
- [David] Yeah, I turned
it off, wah-wah-wah.
And then I hit it again,
and then wow, wow.
- [Gary] I don't understand why--
- [Lou] We have one wow, one
wow, and then we end there.
Wow.
(Lou laughs)
- [Gary] That's not good enough.
- [Lou] It's one less wow than needed.
(upbeat music)
- In 2v2, Gary has Hex got a
little bit of cold feet there
is he a bit scared?
- Listen, Hex is one
of the most important,
significant humans in this entire space.
As much as I would love
to stand up here and say
he got scared or things of that nature
it's just not true, the reality is,
is that you're looking at two
undefeated ownership groups
here right now and what we're focused
on is winning championship.
And we're (bleep) Minnesota!
- [Host] Oh.
(audience cheering)
Okay. (laughs)
- [Panel Member] Yes we are.
- The real north!
I hear you talking Toronto,
Toronto you're (bleep)
North, we own, it's (bleep)
Minnesota up in here!
(audience applause)
(woman laughs)
- Yes!
I love it.
- He can say whatever he wants
because he's running this thing.
- Toronto with that (bleep).
- They paid for half of this.
- Can't curse?
- But guys--
- Oh.
- What do you say to the fans
who are really looking forward--
- Am I banned from YouTube?
(upbeat music)
- Thank you man.
- [Gary] Real pleasure, take care.
- See you in Miami.
- See you in Miami man.
That was great.
Sorry about the cursing,
I didn't didn't know.
(upbeat music)
What a great day man, just fuck!
So much energy, so much excitement.
Reminds me so much of silicon valley 2006,
the space, the energy.
Just like, really really
grateful to be a part of this.
Really really grateful
that we're documenting
this together, D. Rock, it's good stuff.
(upbeat music)
(record scratching)
Make a TikTok, ready?
TikTok, nobody can beat
me in Dig-Dug, nobody.
me in Tapper, nobody.
TikTok, nobody can beat
me in Donkey Kong, nobody.
me in Star Wars, nobody.
TikTok, nobody can beat
me in Pacman, nobody.
(laughs)
- Yeah you're on.
Oh, I'm sorry you're not.
I don't want him to
take a shit without me,
you know what I mean?
I don't want him to take
a fucking shit without me.
All right the lights are on here at...
(laughs)
(whistle blows)
Huge.
Right?
(upbeat music)
I will say this and
this is very important.
The last time I recall such a situation,
Brian told me what kind of
basketball player he was.
And he underperformed.
He underperformed, Brian.
Underperformed.
I'm not cursing today
because Maggie asked me
but you cursed, it turned me off.
I'm a Jersey boy.
Caleb it's terrible, right?
Help me, do you know grammar?
Listen to this, Caleb's
not even good at grammar
and he thinks my grammar's dog shit.
- It's the Weekly Vee.
- In front of the trash.
Ooh!
- Did you just hit him?
- Yeah, again, jeez.
- [Camerawoman] D. Rock
are you getting smoked?
- Harvard.
- [David] Harvard.
Imagine a Jersey boy in Harvard.
(Gary chuckles)
(light playful music)